BIDEN HITTING THE ROAD TO
HIGHLIGHT THE PAST A STIMULUS
BILL FROM LAST WEEK BUT HAS NO
PLANS TO A SOUTHERN BORDER EVEN
AS AS A MINISTRATION SENDS FEMA
TO HELP.
YESTERDAY A GROUP OF REPUBLICAN
LAWMAKERS GOT A FIRST LAND LOOK
AT THE BORDER CRISIS INCLUDING
OUR NEXT GUEST.
JOINING US NOW, TENNESSEE
CONGRESSMAN AND CONGRESSMAN DAVE
JOYCE.
KURTZMAN HERALD, LET’S START
WITH YOU.
WHAT DID YOU EXPECT, WHAT DID
YOU SEE?
>> WELL, I WAS IMPRESSED THAT
THE FACILITY IS OBVIOUSLY
BRAND-NEW AND BEEN OPENED JUST
ONE YEAR AND WHEN THEY BUILT
THIS THEY THOUGHT THEY WOULD
NEVER REACH CAPACITY BUT WHILE
WE WERE THERE YESTERDAY WE WERE
TOLD BY THAT THEY DID INDEED
MEET THEIR CAPACITY YESTERDAY
AND ARE LOOKING FOR OVERFLOW
OPPORTUNITIES EVEN IN THEIR
PARKING LOT BUT THE FACILITY IS
VERY NICE, CONSIDERING THE TRACK
THESE PEOPLE CAME THROUGH TO GET
TO OUR BORDERS.
BRIAN: CONGRESSMAN ROSE, WHO ARE
IN THESE FACILITIES?
>> WE SAW A COMBINATION OF
FAMILIES UNACCOMPANIED MINORS
AND INDIVIDUAL ADULTS THAT ARE
BEING PROCESSED AT THIS
FACILITY.
OBVIOUSLY, THE UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS MAY BE IS THE MOST TRAGIC
OF THE STORIES.
BRIAN: CONGRESSMAN ROSE, DID YOU
SEE A SITUATION WHERE IT WAS AN
OVERWHELMED FACILITY?
ARE WE GETTING TO THAT POINT?
>> I THINK WE ARE GETTING TO
THAT POINT.
THIS FACILITY WAS BUILT TO
ACCOMMODATE ABOUT 100,000 AND
OVER JUST 100,000 INDIVIDUALS OR
I’M SORRY, JUST OVER 1000
INDIVIDUALS AND THEY EXCEEDED
THAT CAPACITY YESTERDAY SO I
THINK THEY ARE PLANNING FOR WHAT
THEY BELIEVE WILL BE A RISING
SURGE WHERE BUT FOR 50% MORE
THAN ANY PREVIOUS POINT IN THIS
YEAR.
BRIAN: CONGRESSMAN JOYCE, IN
TERMS OF WHERE THEY ARE FROM,
WHAT THEY HEAR, WHY THEY CAME, I
KNOW THE LANGUAGE BARRIER IS AN
ISSUE BUT DID YOU GET SOME OF
THE STORIES?
>> I DID NOT PERSONALLY BECAUSE
I’M NOT THAT FLUENT IN SPANISH
BUT CONGRESSMAN JIMENEZ HAD
DISCUSSION WITH THE FAMILIES WHO
WHO MADE A JOURNEY TO FROM HAITI
AND TALKING TO THE AGENTS
THEY’RE COMING FROM ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
CHINA ESPECIALLY PRINT CHINA
BEING THE BIG FISH BECAUSE THEY
WILL PAY $35000 TO BE BROUGHT
INTO THE COUNTRY.
ONE OF THE MOST STAGGERING
STATISTICS I HEARD YESTERDAY WAS
THE IDEA THAT THEY ARE PAYING AN
AVERAGE OF $4000 TO HAVE THESE
COYOTES PUSH THEM INTO THE
COUNTRY.
THINK ABOUT THAT, LAST MONTH
THEY’VE CAUGHT 100,000 AND
THAT’S $400 MILLION.
THINK OF THE PEOPLE WE DID NOT
CATCH.
THAT’S A HUGE FINANCIAL
INCENTIVE.
BRIAN: LET’S LOOK AT THE STATS,
SOUTHERN MIGRATION ENCOUNTERS,
FULL-SCREEN, 100,041 CAME IN
FEBRUARY 21 AND THAT’S UP 20%
FROM JANUARY PRINT UP 174% FROM
FEBRUARY 2020.
THE HIGHEST SINCE JUNE OF 2019
SO THIS IS DONE, CONGRESSWOMAN,
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE SITUATION
WHERE IS THIS HEADING?
WEARABLE BB IN THREE WEEKS?
WHERE WILL WE BE IN A MONTH?
>> THIS IS A CRISIS AT THE
BORDER AND IT DID NOT HAVE TO BE
THIS WAY.
IN FACT, ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUES
SAID IT BEST YESTERDAY,
CONGRESSMAN MACLEOD SAID THIS
ADMINISTRATION COULD HAVE DONE
NOTHING AND IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
BETTER THAN IT IS RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE WE KNOW THE POLICIES OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT WERE
WORKING AT WITH THE REMAIN IN
MEXICO AND WE ARE HOPING THEY
KEEP THE TITLE 42 IN PLACE AND
THAT IS WHAT IS HELPING THE
PUBLIC KEY BORDER THAT ALLOWS
BORDER PATROL AGENTS ALLOWING TO
PROCESS THOSE WHO COME HERE
ILLEGALLY FROM CANADA AND MEXICO
AND EXPEL THEM BACK TO MEXICO OR
CANADA AND THAT IS ONE OF THE
TOOLS THAT IS WORKING, BORDER
PATROL TOLD US YESTERDAY THAT
IT’S BEEN A GODSEND AND THEY
HOPE THAT THAT TITLE 42 STAYS IN
PLACE AND WE HAVE INTRODUCED
LEGISLATION DOING JUST THAT SO
WE ARE HOPING WE CAN GET SOME
LEGS UNDER THAT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AND GET IT THROUGH
SO WE CAN KEEP THAT AVAILABLE
FOR BORDER PATROL AGENTS AND FOR
THE COUNTRY.
BRIAN: UNACCOMPANIED MINORS,
CONGRESSMAN ROSE, WHEN THEY TURN
AROUND AND SAY THIS IS ALL
TRUMP’S FAULT WHO HAS BROKEN
POLICIES, BROKEN BORDER WE
INHERITED WHAT IS YOUR REACTION?
>> THAT IS RIDICULOUS.
I THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN, THE
MESSAGE THAT HE SENT THAT THE
BORDER WOULD BE OPEN AND THAT
THESE INDIVIDUALS SHOULD CALL IS
ENCOURAGING THEM TO COME.
IT’S PUTTING THOSE PEOPLE AND
HARD WAY AS THEY MAKE THE
PERILOUS JOURNEY NORTH.
I THINK IT IS RIDICULOUS TO LAY
THIS AT THE FEET OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP BECAUSE CLEARLY, THIS IS
BIDEN’S CRISIS AND BIDEN’S
SCANDAL.
BRIAN: AND HE WON’T EVEN ADMIT
IT AND NOT LET THE BORDER PATROL
TALK ABOUT IT BUT GET THE STRESS
IS OVERWHELMING.
CONGRESS PEOPLE, HAVE TO LEAVE
IT THERE.
THANK YOU FOR MAKING THE JOURNEY
AND GIVING US YOUR PERSONAL
ACCOUNT OF WHAT YOU SOUGHT